مئه دولار لبرميل الديزل وخمسه واربعون
للفيول وغيره من المنتجات النفطيه منخفضه
الجوده هذه هي الاسقف التي قرر الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرضها ابتداء من الخامس من
فبراير
2023 على ما تصدره روسيا من مشتقات
البترول
الاوروبيون سيسمحون للبلدان غير الاوروبيه
وشركات نقل النفط التي تتعامل مع روسيا
ابرام عقود التامين والتمويل مع مؤسسات
غربيه فقط اذا احترموا السقف المقرر
اوروبيا حسب مراقبين فان الرد الروسي على
العقوبات الاوروبيه سيكون بسيطا لكن صارما
موسكو ستوقف او تحد من تصدير الديزل
لاوروبا التي تغطي نصف حاجياتها من روسيا
وبالتالي ستتعطل مصانعها وستقف الشاحنات
والحافلات لكيلومترات
المحطات الوقود
البدائل المتاحه لاعضاء الكتله الاوروبيه
كلها بعيده وغاليه ومعقده لوجستيا اذا ما
لجات لاستيراد الديزل وغيره من مواد
بتروليه من بلدان كندند والصين وبالتالي
ستكون الاقتصادات الاوروبيه اذا ما طبق
القرار اول متضرر من العقوبات
اقتصادات ما زالت تعاني من ازمه الغاز
الروسي التي ادت الى رفع تكلفه التدفئه
وانتاج الكهرباء في اوروبا بعد قطع روسيا
الامداداتها من الغاز المسال فستكون
اوروبا حسب متابعين كمن اطلق النار على
رجله مرتين
انس نماسي العربيه